und sie hat mich immer noch an gestartet
wenn ich zurückgegangen gefragt kann ich
irgendwie helfen und er meinte sie
einfach ganz direkt ins gesicht ich
beobachte sie nur weil bei negern muss
ja immer auch muss man ja mal aufpassen
was sie so gefährlich ist aus der tasche
ziehen dass man unterschätzt wird dass
man fähigkeiten abgesprochen bekommt
dass man stereotyp visiert wird dass
menschen anfangen in die plötzlich
langsamer oder deutlicher mit einem zu
sprechen
manchmal gerne auch etwas lauter und
bringt er ja ok verstehe ich jetzt nicht
was das ganze soll rassismus wird
offener direkter weil die leute sich
jetzt ganz offensichtlich trauen dinge
die sie zuvor vielleicht im kleinen
kreis geäußert haben um noch ein
öffentlichkeit zu sagen in jeglichen
bereichen ist man damit konfrontiert und
es ist ein täglicher begleiter und die
banalisierung dessen dass es in
deutschland keine probe kein problem ist
führt dazu dass man sich auch hier
natürlich nicht ernst genommen fühlt im
adressieren von anti schwarzen rassismus
der hier existiert werden auch gerne der
begriff kommissions kinder ja so ganz
niedlich sind und das ist sehr wenig in
der tat sehr schwierig da haben auch
große teile der politik und der medien
ihren teil dazu beigetragen dass diese
menschen sich jetzt wohl fühlen oder das
gefühl haben sie türen in rassismus ganz
offen zur schau stellen weil angeblich
in ihrem weltbild eines schweigende
mehrheit hinter ihnen steht in dem
augenblick wo man ihm zuhören sollte
wird das gespräch verdreht das sind dann
zum beispiel so momente wo dann setzte
weil die aber es gibt ja auch rassismus
gegen weiße die auseinandersetzung mit
diesem thema politisch wie
gesellschaftlich muss viel stärker
stattfinden wir haben in deutschland
keine aufarbeitung in der form die
notwendig ist um zu verstehen wie
rassismus eigentlich in deutschland halt
auch salonfähig geworden ist gegenüber
schwarzen menschen dass menschen die
selbst vielleicht nicht von rassismus
betroffen sind sich trotzdem aktiv gegen
rassismus positionieren und zwar nicht
nur auf social media gerne auch auf
social media aber es mussten schritt
weiter gehen wir müssen auch im alltag
bereits sein unsere stimme zu erheben
wir müssen ehrlich
hinweise finden mit der debatte um zu
gehen und zwar sehr ehrliche debatte in
der es um die gefühle der betroffenen
geht nicht um die gefühle von denen und
den rassismus ausgeht
ich glaube es geht aber gar nicht dort
oben grundsätzlich nur anschuldigung zu
machen sondern einmal zu erklären woher
kommen die was ist nun was können wir
dagegen tun um als gesellschaft gemeint
zu sein ganz oft erlebe ich diesen flex
form von weißen freundin dann alles in
frage zu stellen also bist du dir sicher
dass das rassistisch gemeint war ein
bildest du das vielleicht ein bist du
vielleicht ein bisschen empfindlich ich
kann mir das überhaupt nicht vorstellen
und da sag ich mal hast du kannst es dir
nicht vorstellen weil du weißt ist und
deswegen als zierlich ist die als dein
freund bitte glauben ja